the framework today provides detail on
what as of now
we expect our next changes to be
firstly it confirms that if all goes
according to plan
we will move fully back to a level
system from the last week in april
at that stage we hope that all parts of
the country currently
in level four will be able to move out
of level four
and back initially to level three
possibly with some revision to the
content of the levels
and afterwards to levels dependent on
incidence and prevalence
of the virus at that time the advantages
of the level system of course is that it
will allow us to let some parts of the
country move
faster than others if the data supports
that
moving back to the variable level system
at that time will also be contingent on
us
having vaccinated all jcvi priority
groups one to nine which as i said
earlier
we hope to have done by mid-april that
matters not only because these groups
will be more protected but also because
we believe
that vaccinating around half of the
population will have a significant
effect on reducing transmission
across society as a whole and although
we don't yet know exactly how big an
effect that will be we do hope and
believe
it will give us the head room to
carefully ease restrictions
is therefore from the last week of april
that we would expect to see
phased but significant reopening of the
economy
including non-essential retail
hospitality and services like gyms and
hairdressers
and of course the more of us who are
vaccinated and the more we all stick by
the rules
now the faster that safe pace is likely
to be if we all stay in this together
our progress will be greater as i said
earlier
we will set out more detail in mid-march
on the indicators that will guide
our decisions on levels as well as on
any revision to the content of each
level
and we take account of our experience
and of sectoral views
and also the order in which we expect
those parts of the economy that have
been restricted to start reopening from
the last week of april
i want now though to set out the journey
from here to the end of april
we envisage a progressive easing of the
current level four restrictions that
apply across most of
the country at intervals of at least
three weeks
along with changes nationally on
education and care home visiting
and the immediate priority will continue
to be the return of schools
all of these easings will of course
depend on an assessment that it is safe
to proceed
the first easing started yesterday with
the partial return of schools
in addition universities and colleges
are able to bring back a small number of
students
no more than five percent of the total
where face-to-face teaching
is critical we will also ease
restrictions on care home visiting from
early march and guidance
it was set out at the weekend the next
phase of easing will be a minimum of
three weeks later
so indicatively from march the 15th
we hope that this will include the next
phase of school return which will start
with the rest of primary school years
four to seven and also getting more
senior phase secondary pupils back in
the classroom
for at least part of their learning we
also hope
in this phase to restart outdoors
non-contact group sports for 12
to 17 year olds and we will also aim to
increase the limit on outdoor mixing
between households
to four people from a maximum of two
households compared to two
people from two households just now and
then
a minimum of three weeks after that so
from the 5th of april
it is our hope and expectation
at this stage that the stay-at-home
restriction will be lifted
we would aim for any final phase of
school return to take place
on this date communal worship will also
we hope
restart around the 5th of april albeit
with restricted numbers to begin with
however in deciding the exact date for
this we will obviously take account of
the timing
of major religious festivals for example
easter and passover so it may be
a few days earlier when communal worship
can restart
and we will seek to ease the
restrictions on household gatherings
further so that at least six people from
two households can meet together
in this phase we will also begin the
reopening of retail
that will start with an extension of the
definition of essential retail and the
removal of restrictions on click
and collect and then three weeks after
that as i indicated earlier so from the
26th of april assuming
the data allows it we will move back to
levels with hopefully all of scotland
that is currently in level four moving
to level three
albeit with some possible modifications
and at that stage
we will begin to reopen the economy and
society in the more substantial way
that we are all longing for is of course
important for me to stress
that all of this depends on us
continuing to suppress the virus now and
continuing to accept
some trade-offs for a period for example
in international travel
but if we do so i am very optimistic
that we can make good progress
in returning more normality to our lives
and to the economy
i know this is still a cautious approach
which though
absolutely essential to control the
virus and protect health is nevertheless
extremely difficult for many businesses
the scottish government is committed to
continuing support
for businesses for example provided we
receive confirmation
of consequentials in the march budget we
will support the strategic framework
business fund
until at least the end of june we will
also ensure that when local authority
areas move out of level four
businesses that are allowed to reopen
will continue to receive payments from
the fund
for at least the next four weeks as they
transition back
to trading more normally we're also
considering some form of tapered support
for businesses
that may still face trading restrictions
and reduce demand
even as they're allowed to reopen and
the finance secretary will set out
further details
shortly we will work with business
organizations on these and many other
issues as we
continue to emerge from lockdown in
addition to the concerns of business
i know that people across the country
are anxious for as much clarity as
possible
i want to give as much as possible today
while avoiding
giving false assurance or picking
arbitrary dates that have no grounding
at this stage
in any objective assessment i am as
confident as i can be
that the indicative staged timetable
that i've set out today
from now until late april when the
economy will start to substantially
reopen
is a reasonable one and in mid-march
when we have made further progress on
vaccines and of greater understanding
of the impacts of the initial phase of
school return i hope we can set out then
more detail
on the further reopening that will take
place over april and may
and into a summer when we hope i really
hope
to be living with much greater freedoms
than we are today
for now however the most important
priority we still
all have is to continue to suppress the
virus and of course
for a bit longer that means sticking to
the current lockdown rules
so please continue to stick to both the
letter and the spirit of them please
stay at home except for essential
purposes
for now don't meet people from other
households indoors
and follow facts when you are out and
about please
continue to work from home wherever
possible and for employers please
continue to support your employees to
work
from home by doing all of this we will
make it easier for children to return to
school more quickly
and we can continue to suppress the
virus even as we follow this path out of
lockdown
and as we do all of this we can keep
each other safe protect
the nhs while giving the vaccination
program the time to do its work
and i know how hard all of this
continues to be after
11 long months of this pandemic but the
restrictions
are working the vaccination program is
motoring
and we can now see a firm way out of
this so if we all stick
together and stick with it we do now
we are now able to see with confidence
that we are looking at much brighter
times ahead so please for now though
stay at home to protect the nhs
and save lives thank you very much
the first minister will now take
questions on the issues raised in their
statement
i intend to allow around 40 minutes uh
for the questions after which we will
move on to the next item of business
it would be helpful if members who wish
to ask a question were to press the
request to speak buttons now
and i call on ruth davidson thank you
deputy presiding officer
after a year where all our lives have
been put on pause there is finally a
growing sense that this might be over
soon and while it's too early to declare
anything like victory
we are starting to win the race between
the vaccine rollout and the spread of
the virus
and we're grateful to all who are
delivering the vaccine program
the edinburgh university study this week
which found that getting the job can cut
hospital admissions
by up to a remarkable 94 was better
than could have been hoped the success
of the vaccine program
means it is now possible to start to
have those important conversations with
friends and family
about reconnecting about making plans
and about getting all of our lives
back on track and we welcome the
information that's contained within the
statement today particularly the details
on school return and care home visits
however there is much
that is not in this statement there is
nothing for the thousands of scots
who've had medical treatment tests or
operations cancelled about when and how
services will get back up to speed
there's nothing for those who've already
postponed huge life events like weddings
for a year
about when they can walk down the aisle
in front of family and friends and
there's nothing about when measures
like social distancing will end and we
can do something as basic
as give a loved one a hug
the statement and the accompanying
documents relate almost exclusively
to the time between now and the 26th of
april where the first minister intends
to move the whole country
to level 3 restrictions pandemic
permitting which to be clear
under current rules would still stop
people leaving their council area
but there is nothing about what happens
after the 26th of april
this isn't a route map out of covid it
is a holding document for the next eight
weeks
and everyone understands that we might
not be able to give people absolute
certainty
but they were expecting the first
minister to give them some kind of hope
many will have tuned in today precisely
because they were expecting to receive
that
they didn't tune in today expecting to
be told to tune in
again in three weeks time and they have
a right to be disappointed
first minister why won't you let the
people of scotland know the plan
to get them fully out of lockdown and
back to their lives
first minister firstly on nhs
operations and treatments nhs
re-mobilization is underway the health
secretary keeps parliament updated on
that i'll ask her to write
to members to give a further update on
that
as soon as she's able to um on weddings
i would hope that as we go into
at the period after at the end of april
we will be able to see
at weddings uh with greater numbers of
people although possibly uh
in likelihood still restricted taking
place
um i as i have always done i'm trying to
be frank with people i
i think we can all be much more hopeful
today than we have been able to be
throughout this entire pandemic not just
because
we have evidence that lockdown is
suppressing the virus
but that we have growing evidence that
we have an alternative
to lockdown restrictions that will uh
suppress the virus
instead of lockdown restrictions over
the longer term and that of course
is vaccination and that does allow us to
say
that we think by the time we get to
april we can start to open up
the economy and between them and april
we can open up
in a gradual and phased way some aspects
of the current restrictions that are in
place
but we have to balance that with the
reality and it's not a reality i enjoy
and it's not a reality anybody enjoys
that there is still uncertainty
and there is still uncertainty about the
impact of the vaccination on
transmission although all of the
evidence that is now emerging on that is
positive and we need to make sure
that we are not opening up while the
virus is still hovering and simmering
at levels that are too high for us
safely to do that
so the further into the future we go the
reality is
any dates that we give at this stage are
more arbitrary
it's like you know putting your finger
in the wind and coming up with the date
that is not
firmly based in the evidence and that
is the balance that we are seeking to
strike by mid-march
we will have uh evidence of the impact
of the early return of schools and we
will have more
evidence i hope on the impact of
vaccination so by then we will be able
to
go forward a little bit more and give
more detail
in that april into me period this is all
going in the right direction but this is
the moment where we have to be
optimistic and positive but also patient
and sensible as well the last thing i
want to be
doing at any point the last thing any of
us want to be doing at any point this
year
is going backwards this must be a firm
and sustainable route out of lockdown
and that is what i believe
that we are putting in place